the water swept away houses and  belongings  many people have lost everything the  romanian city of core today are hers is  almost completely submerged in the  surrounding area people are trying to  save what they can many are shocked at  the scale of the flooding I'm 61 I've  lived here my whole life and I've never  seen anything like this in Italy also  hit by the rains families salvaged these  pieces of furniture water levels surged  along the river or Luna and lombardi a  region prone to flooding parts of  Belgium are also under water on Tuesday  night emergency services used this  improvised method to rescue families  from their flooded homes in the volume  per bond province here and elsewhere  it's bound to take months to repair the  damage